all right what's our agenda today I will
do a little bit of theory we'll talk
about artificial intelligence versus
machine learning I'll just drop a little
line about deep learning because
everybody wants to know about it but
it's a full different topic so if what
you really wanted to learn today is like
how to build your own neural networks
and stuff like that might not be the
best place but you still get a little
bit of an introduction so what I want
you to get at the end of this is to not
be intimidated by the world of art of
machine learning at the end so we'll
talk about different algorithms
supervised unsupervised and we'll go
through the an example of a naive Bayes
classifier which is one basic algorithm
and the genetic algorithm it's a lot of
content hopefully we'll have the time to
go through this and we'll have a few
maybe a five minutes for fqa I
understand is the last talk of the day
so some people might be in a hurry to
get back home so we'll see how that goes
so let's get started artificial
intelligence if you google it you'll
probably see images like that typically
a woman probably the intelligence part
I'm usually covered with like circuit
boards and stuff like that probably the
artificial part and usually some code do
you see anything wrong with this code
it's Jake jQuery it's bootstrap actually
probably not the best example of machine
learning stuff but anyways artificial
intelligence artificial intelligence is
intelligence exhibited by machines so in
the field of AI research we define it as
any device that perceives its
environment and takes actions to
maximize its chances to success at some
goal a little bit fascist on this
specific part so artificial intelligence
is just a set of rules that will be used
in order to make some sort of
intelligence so it's just a series of
ifs basically what does it look like in
the real life that is one very good
example so each one of those goes
although you've probably all played
pac-man at least if you're my age and
you know you've tried and you kind of
have that feeling that they're all
chasing after you and they have like
they're they're very
smart but actually they're very very
stupid they follow very stupid rules and
they're all different
so blinky the red one will just follow
you doesn't really matter where you're
at it just tries to reach as fast as you
can
blinky sorry pinkie kind of tries to
predict your movement based on where
you're headed so if I think it goes into
opposite directions so it kind of gives
you a feeling that it's trying to track
you from another way inky's position
will highly depend on Blinky's and quite
interestingly enough which is the orange
one will never cash back man as soon as
it gets close enough it goes in a
different direction and that's the way
it was built and there's a reason for
that it gives an impression that Clyde
tries to go another way to attack you
but that's not the case like really
can't totally ignore him so your are now
pac-man experts so if you got some one
thing out of this talk seriously though
so it's just a series of rules and they
follow those rules to kind of mimic
artificial intelligence so that's what
in artificial intelligence is other
examples in real life more modern
examples would be credit cards where
they have like a set of arbitrary rules
say a transact transaction is made in
the foreign country the card gets
cancelled happens to me all the time
when I travel in is very annoying but
yeah those are rules that are arbitrary
used in your software machine learning
on the other hand is a subset of
computer science that gives a computer
the ability to learn without being
explicitly programmed so rather than
programming the rules we are programming
a way for our software to learn the
rules right so there are various
examples I have a nest thermostat at
home I'm not sure if any of you have one
and I didn't mention it at the beginning
but I live in Canada and we have very
very cold weather in the in the winter
and very hot in the summer and so you
kind of basically always have to retrain
your your thermostat but when I when
comes fall or when comes spring
my term instead will just show up a
message saying okay well time to train
me and then I'll just adjust the
temperature whenever makes sense for me
when I am at home or when I'm leaving
and so on and after a while I just start
this sets itself automatically just a
few minutes before I come home so you
know the house is nice and cool during
summer and hot and cozy
during winter so that's a good example
of machine learning so nobody actually
programmed their rules into a thermostat
I just programmed a way for a thermostat
to make its own rules Siri Cortana
okay Google and so on they all have
their own machine learning algorithms
built in I've mentioned the example of
you know detecting when it's time to go
to work and stuff like that and there's
also the very interesting case of tape
so I'm not sure if anybody heard about a
it was a chat bot that was introduced by
Microsoft about a year ago just over a
year ago and some people heard about it
and yeah and she was meant to to learn
from her interaction outside in the real
world
and so they've deployed it over Twitter
and she would respond to both public
tweets and direct messages and when she
got deployed she was super stoked to be
part of the human world very very
excited that was on March 23rd at 8:30
about 12 hours later she started not to
be so happy about being with the humans
few hours later yeah and it wasn't
getting any better
that's 24 hours after it left after it
was launched so they've closed it
but say all in all is a very very good
example of the machine learning
algorithms so it was basically a blank
slate she didn't know nothing and she
should just learn from the interactions
you know when my mom saw that in the
news she kind of got panicked and she's
how my god like the computers will
dominate the world and you know
computers will want to kill us and how
can a computer become a Nazi and well
you know the thing is that it really
learned from the interactions from
humans so really you don't have to be
afraid of you know machine learning be
afraid of humans so I kinda lost hope in
humanity at that point it also makes you
realize that it was very very important
that you add defense mechanism in you in
your algorithm because there will always
be trolls trying to find a way to
exploit whatever you're putting out
there so be careful with that back to
our program
deep learning so it's it's no surprise
to all of you that there's a lot and a
lot of data that is available out there
everybody gathers data Google gathers
data whenever you're going on whatever
website that you're going on
Facebook is any single enterprise is
probably trying to get some data from
you and they have all of this stuff and
all of this data and there's also all of
those cute little kitten videos that get
posted on YouTube and all of those
weather data and all that scientific
that and how do you make sense of all of
that and there is no way nowadays to
process all of that manually
you need to you need to use new
algorithms even with the typical
computing that we used to do which would
just use a loop and see if there's a
correlation between you know the number
of visits on my website versus the
weather outside it's going to be is
going to be very computing costly so you
need kind of new tools and new ways to
do that and that's where deep learning
comes into play and deep learning will
typically use neural networks as well in
order to learn and make sense of that
data like I said
spend too much time on it but as real
thumb basically it's just a way to break
down data into smaller chunks and to
make sense out of it so in this very
specific example data comes in and it
tries to detect if there is some sort of
shadow patterns that it can kind of make
sense out of it and if it does it goes
to a next layer passes its it passes on
that information and the next layer will
try to see if those shadow patterns are
kind of face something in your face and
then they if so it will move on to the
next level and try to detect if there's
an actual face on the image if there's
two eyes our nose and about then it's
probably a face right so neural networks
is a nice way to break down into smaller
chunks there's much more to that but I
don't want to get into it first of all
because I don't really know anything
about it
but also because it's a whole different
subject if if you are interested though
there is a tensor flow which is a very
interesting open source library which
runs on Python that you can use in order
to build your own networks and there's
also a bunch of different cloud options
now available IBM Watson being one and
Google also has a cloud computing
artificial machine learning thingy it's
probably not all that don't all right so
let's look into some algorithms we're
almost there actually so there are so
many types of algorithms in machine
learning the first one is the supervised
learning algorithm so supervised
learning requires user feedback as its
name mentions so it starts with no
knowledge at all you feed it data and it
will eventually get better and better at
doing whatever it's meant to do now it's
completely useless if you provide it
with invalid data or use this
information so it's really a garbage in
garbage out type of scenario today is
one good example of that type of
feedback mechanism where we provided it
with bad data and it eventually started
spitting out invalid outputs it's
typically used in classifiers so
whenever you want to do something that
will automatically detect if it goes in
box a or box B and that's what you'll
use so it's a classifier so it'd
classify stuff into different categories
it can be used for if you want to detect
the language of a text for example so
you can eventually start teaching your
algorithm how to detect if it's in
French or in English that's one example
that is true later on it can also be
used if you've provided with enough data
it can also even detect if an author of
a book or an article is a male or a
female because it's Melton to use
certain specific words more than women
so eventually you can teach your
algorithm to kind of detect that type of
pattern as well so if you provide it
with enough information eventually it
can detect pretty much anything
unsupervised learning on the other hand
it's a little bit hard to understand or
and/or to explain but it's an algorithm
that doesn't necessarily require
feedback so you'll use it in the case
where you don't really care what the the
whole reasoning is or there's whenever
there's no real right or wrong answer
but it's all like gray areas so I'll try
to show you examples later on that will
hopefully make this a little bit more
clear so it's used mostly to group
behaviors to identify patterns so if
you're trying to kind of know if you
want to know what type of users are
browsing your website and it will kind
of try to identify different patterns to
give you that information so that's
mostly what it's used for
all right let's look at our first
algorithm whoever says machine learning
says Matt's right so the Neve the base
theorem mentions that the probability of
having a or B depends of the probability
of a over B which can be then converted
in a nice
way to read and the probability of a
over the probability of a plus one minus
the probability of being over a times
one minus probability of a which can be
simplified like this so it's the sum of
all the probabilities of a to lie over
the sum of all probabilities of all
right that's not true you don't need
Matz to do machine learning that's one
of the things that I learned well you
kind of needs a little basic arithmetic
but not that much so we'll look at an
example that is a little bit more simple
so you know we've all seen Forrest Gump
so you know how he says life is like a
box of chocolate you never know what
you're going to get so is that true
let's see so say you have a box of
chocolate and and you're allergic to
nuts right so you don't want to pick one
that has nuts in it and you know that
round chocolate tend to have less nuts
than square ones and dark chocolate have
much less nuts than light ones all right
so we can convert that into some mats in
order to find out if a round light
chocolate will have nuts or not so we
convert those percentage into decimals
and then we just do the sum of them so
point 25 time point nine gives you point
two two five and same thing on the other
side and then you simply apply this
simple formula which is the base theorem
and it gives you a 75% chance that light
round chocolate has nuts in it
so don't eat it if you're allergic
actually if you are allergic to not
don't use that like it's probably not
safe but still all right so all it is is
simply a very very simple probability
calculation so in this case we're
looking at a very dead simple example
but that's all there is to it it's only
a calculation is there a probability
that something is more X or more Y so
that's all there is to classifiers all
classifiers follow the same structure
basically there's a training method in
this case I've named do you classify so
you provided some sort of input and then
you provided a category if you want to
do something more complex you can
classify images you can classify all
kind of things and we can be used if you
want to check if there is a tumor into
x-rays and stuff like that eventually it
can learn how to detect if is there one
or not all the magic goes into your
classify function the way you structure
all of your data actually I was wrong
all the magic goes into the categorize
function categories just gives you an
input so you provided with something and
it will tell you in which category fits
in all right let's look at a demo
all right so that's everybody no tinder
nobody ever knows tinder oh there's one
of them okay all right so it's an
interface that looks like tinder from
what I've been told so we will simply
slide a card whether the text is in
French or in English and we'll try to
teach this algorithm and right now it
has absolutely no data so I've removed
the all of the data from it beforehand
so this one is in French in English all
right it'll just take a while Oh
actually was pretty fast so as you can
see it says that this text is in English
so it actually already detected that
some of the words there are typically
more there's a bigger chance that those
words are in English than in French so
if we go on it doesn't detect all of
them for now okay it'll eventually get
there okay so as you can see there's
another one I could do this all day like
it's so much fun trust me eventually
gets better alright so as you can see
that can now detect French if we
continue a little bit it should get
better better alright so as you can see
it's getting yeah it's getting pretty
good right now so that's a very simple
way to use it and it's a very good valid
case for classifiers so you can detect
whether a text is in French or in
English so what does the code look like
it has to be super complicated right all
right so it's about 100 lines long okay
it's definitely not the most optimal
this being said PHP is probably not the
most optimal language to do machine
learning as well especially if you
specifically not this one just because I
have to reload all of the data every
time so at one point it would become
really really slow but just for the
purpose of this talk I wrote this one in
a simple way so I may put my
first into doing something which is a
little bit hopefully readable then
actually optimized it's like I said you
have two main functions so train and
categorize and everything else is
private the other functions that are
private is the cleanup which I type I
take some words and I'll just make sure
that there's no weird characters in
there and I ignore worse that I have
less than two characters and there's a
bunch of small rules but it's not very
important and save and read and all that
they do is that they will save all of
their data into a file so it will just
take all of my dictionaries save it into
a file and just reframe it whenever I
want to do a categories so my training
function is essentially just storing all
of that data into a big object so I just
put all of the words in there and I
increment and I put it in the category
that it was assigned to and I just think
from end account for each word every
time that the algorithm detects it so
that helps if you have some some words
that can be used both in French and
English in this case stuff like I don't
know but a PC can be used in both
languages or even a sentence could
contain the word JavaScript so is it
French or English then it's hard to say
but you will see that there is a better
chance that it's in one or the other if
you increase those counters so that's
all I do I just build this small
dictionary here and then in the
categories then this one is a little bit
of a mess so what I do is that I take
the string that is provided to it
breaking down into different words I do
my cleanup function on it just remove
all the useless stuff and then I just
give it a score so for every every time
I check into my dictionary is this word
part of my dictionary if it is what's
the score for English was the score for
French and then I'll just add so I'll
have a score for one category and a
score for another one
and then at the end I just spit out the
probability of which one is the higher
and when I reach a certain threshold I
say okay this is the one
this is the category rien so I'm
obviously after the first card if you
pick up an English card right away
there's a fair chance but based on some
of the calculations that are done there
it won't give you at the right language
right away we'll try to make the data
more flat on the data a little bit more
so that it's provides you with a better
guess all right
first algorithm done that was easy so
far sentiment analysis sentiment
analysis is often confused as being a
machine learning algorithm but it's not
so it's just using a simple set of rules
so it's more artificial intelligence
than machine learning why do I talk
about it well it uses the exact same
type of classifiers actually but rather
than using a dictionary that gets built
up over time it just uses a set of data
that is already provided to it and every
one of those words will have a score
associated with that so words like
awesome will have a higher score than
words like I don't care so it will
eventually give a give escort you're the
string that you've provided to it and
typically it's from plus 5 to minus 5
plus 5 being something that is super
positive minus 5 being something that is
very negative and it can be used often
for PR agencies that try to get a sense
of you know what what does the general
public think of something and it's used
a lot in the elections you'll see all
people tend to favor blah blah blah it
will be done through a sentiment
analysis if you want to do it JavaScript
there's a NPM library that is available
and in PHP there's a composer library
that is available as well so you just
install it and there's generally just
one method that you can use just provide
it with some text and it will spit out a
score so it's very very simple to use
all right on to my favorite subject
genetic algorithm
awesome [ __ ] alright remember when you
roll your first hello world and you were
like super excited and you came back
home you're like look mom I just rolled
this program and all those 12 lines of
code they spit out hello world on the
screen and she was like yes so what just
type hello world right so no we don't
get hit like I've put in so much time
and so much okay genetic algorithm is
the same thing if you have a bit of free
time definitely try to program your own
it's super fun and you true you so it to
people and nobody will care so I will
show you mine please fake it you know
alright so how does that work well
basically it tries to mimic elevate a
live evolutionary theories from Darwin
so you'll take a population of
individuals and out of that population
you will keep the best elements so those
that are close the closest to the
solution that you're kind of going for
after a while so after that you will
keep some random individuals that are
not the top individuals you will
introduce some random mutations in there
then you will take whatever those
elements are and out of those you'll
pick random individuals to create
children which will share some of the
properties of the random individuals and
then magically you end up with a valid
solution alright if it wasn't awesome
enough okay let's let me recap this we
create a population random individuals
keep the closest keep a few random
individuals random mutations random
children and magically you get a
solution right in the real world it
looks a little bit like this
dreamcatcher is an application that is
developed by Adobe and my team has
worked a little bit on this one so it
will help you to create different models
say you want to print a bike frame and
you can have different criterias maybe
you want the one that
is the most solid maybe you want the one
that is the lightest and based on those
criterias you will it will provide you
different mutations different structures
that could be lighter or more solid and
stuff like that same thing if you want
to build a drum skeleton you'll probably
want something that is 30 but still very
light weight let's look at a demo all
right so in this demo what I did sorry
so what I did here is that I asked my
application to find a set of four
individual four float numbers that would
give me a sum of 200 all right
don't try to figure out what's the use
case for that there's none okay so the
only thing that I'm trying to do is
let's let's find four individuals for
which the sum is 200 all right so what I
will do is that it will throw up random
numbers do those random mutations and so
on and eventually spit out an answer
with four float numbers that sum up to
200 there we go thank you
like I said not impressive okay but the
fun thing is that if you look at those
numbers they actually sum up to very
close to 200 if I run it again I'll get
a completely difference of a solution
and it will take a different number of
generations it takes anywhere between
100 and a few thousand generations
before it finds her right solution and
every time is different so when I said
that it doesn't in this case it doesn't
really matter the solution there's no
right or wrong answer the only thing
that I want is a possible solution that
would be close to whatever I'm looking
for and because it goes throughout all
of those random solutions it ends up
with something that is close but I'm I
was you know it gives me something in
different every time and that's an
interesting one so as you can see those
two are the same because they share the
same parent they shared
you have probably parents somewhere and
it gave to two numbers that are the same
okay so does that how does it look like
so genetic algorithms always have pretty
much the same function and so let's
ignore the setters at the beginning
initialize will simply give me a random
population so in this case I want 200
individuals in my population so 200
arrays of four elements right one
individual is an array of four elements
and initialized just fills up random
completely random array I have a
function that returns me the best
individuals or the best individual in
the in the whole array so out of my
population I want to know which one is
the closest and I'll use that to see if
if I have a valid answer or not and the
fitness function is where all the magic
happens in those algorithms so Fitness
is a calculation to see how close am I
to the real answer so because I have a
very simple case I simply check whether
a a plus B how close or April not a plus
B but equals B plus C plus D how close
is it to 200
and it will return me closest to zero
will be very close to 200 if you wanted
to find a model for a bike that is the
lightest that's where you would try to
figure it out so you calculate this the
mass of all the product that you've used
and is it close to the lightest weight
that I could might want to get or not
and then I have functions to sort it by
Fitness I have functions to mutate which
just basically randomly change one of
the individuals one of the elements
inside the individual and I have the
reproduced function which just takes the
first two elements and the last two
elements from a parent and a mother or
father and a mother and creates a new
children based on that
so my evolve function basically just
just iterates that over and over and it
will sort all my arrays by all my
population by fitness I then take a few
of the best elements which I use to
create a new array I'll just introduce
some random elements from the original
array as well and then I'll just let it
randomly introduce mutations if needed
so there's a probability that there will
be around the mutation there and then I
just feel the rest of the array so that
I'm back at my original population
number 200 in my case with random r with
children that are created based on
random father and mothers and that's it
so I just checked whenever I want to
solve it I just loop and I just do and
evolve on my population up to a point
where I get a solution that is
acceptable and that's what we that's
what you get so you get a solution and
that is close to what you wanted all
right because my example wasn't very
mind-blowing I'll use something that
somebody else did hopefully internet
will be good with me so in this very
specific example
that's a group of students that tried to
model eyes and try to see if they could
teach a model how to walk so what they
did is that they've told their days
they've took a model they specified
where are the joints were the muscles
what are the what's the flex that the
muscle can do and based on that they
just ran a few models using genetic
algorithms right we're almost there so
you see that after a few generations it
kind of starts to learn to walk but it
takes a while and the fitness function
in that case is the distance that is
that is done or how far can the creature
let's call it can walk as well as how
straight it walks
right yeah just because it's so much fun
let's take a look at these
I like this one alright yeah it pretty
much works so that's the interesting
thing some of the solutions that came
out of that experiment we're almost
working as you can see in this case
eventually it falls down a bit and
that's why you need to introduce random
mutations because if once it gets into a
state where it's kind of trying to do
that it'll kind of just try to get
better at doing something like this and
you want it to start walking straight
again so you'll let introduce random
mutations with will which will help
changing the direction a little bit and
hopefully get a random solution that is
a little bit better and then what's
happening right now all right Brandon
you're running out of time too much fun
here okay so a structure of the code
typically looks like this so I've shown
it into my ID all right so what did we
learn well you all know the difference
between machine learning and artificial
intelligence so you can now be a
smartass and correct every one that uses
not in the right right way we've learned
that I don't know anything about big
data and deep learning supervised and
unsupervised algorithms and we've seen
naive Bayes sentiment analysis and
genetic algorithm what I hope you'll
gain out of this is not necessarily how
to do it but I hope that you won't be
intimidated by it anymore the first time
when I really wanted to get into it and
I needed to do something for an
application it felt overwhelming it's
very very Academy called this stuff
you'll find on Google there's a lot of
math involved and as you can see don't
really need to go deep into math and you
don't need to read all of that academic
papers that's all I have for today
thank you
[Applause]